and the play wasn't dead hit him in the back
they went the net well and that rule was
changed shortly thereafter and now they look
to see if it's a legal goal they can review
for that here comes Lin hit the go post Patrick
[Music] Kane got to see Kane's [Music] reaction
one quick one got some line changes going
on nice play by D Bret rocking off the far
goal posted Patrick Kan [Applause] NE a
very good season this year too with 16
goals point shot in off the
Break It Go scars kaning gets
another [Applause] [Music] [Applause] one [Music]
well they got a really really fortuitous bounce
right here the game fourth of the Season scored
by number 88a Waits looks for an open man and
he's got one and fair be nice move in tight in on
goal and they score they get it back it's Bobby or
Brink well we have to see why this ended
up a two-on one mean there's a lot of En
enthusiasm on the offense when you score
two goals like that like Detroit scor by
number 88 patri so hall Hall is uh got
caught pinching now they've been pinching
a little bit here early and getting away
with it and forcing the port check to be
good and Brink doesn't make much of a
move cabry got it back to cider now for
Raymond cider temp the but the score perfectly to
sprung power play goal it's 3 to [Music]
[Applause] one there a nice shot pass
right there or in one of them I guess yeah
is it real Detroit power the season behind
for Raymond centering feet big stop rebound
Baleno and a scolling up they score go to the
net good things happened coer bangs at [Music]
home but this thing was a real hot potato and
it just could not find a home with a white
jersey CLK circling wide now around Forester
in front of the goal for Kane just missed
him cider gosis bear to Brink it looks like
a power play but it's not here here's Kane
with a shot just why rebound they score what
a play by Kane off the back [Music] courts and
Costa spear buried it 15 41 down low I'd have
to read this again to see if Kane purposely
shot wide or not I I don't think he did but
boy oh boy what a again the P check pressure by
Detroit they had the Philadelphia Flyers hemmed
in tried to Center but in his way was Owen tippet
foring away forier back it comes for sand on
the score that may have changed Direction in
front of the net it did and it's 52 yeah
it was a a tip in that the puck dropped
does cachua 14 get a stick on it he does let's
get it back together right now don't give them
anything else button down the ship defensively
scores another one that's what you were
saying crost get that it looked like
it I think sounded like it got tipped
and it was sanheim I think with the shot
a one face off in their Zone the Flyers
get a bunch of tricky good bounces for
them and sanheim just goes it a net with
it Joe valeno with an assist tonight seven
goals 13 points on the season for number 90
lton 60 ft the shot he scores that may
have been tipped in front too it was is
that halfway yep so one shot game now it's a
Bo I think it looks like a little below the
crossbar and it definitely cleared by GS Spar
ahead for cop who wants a change pack for Joel
farab dropped off for Lon the Forester save made
rebound and they score it's a tie [Applause]
game it was it looked on side big rebound
right there Lucas Raymond came over he got
bodied and the Flyers will bring it out
chot trying to catch up the shot rer look
behind him they score oh and tip it tipped
it home it's 6 to5 Philadelphia all the way
back from a 5-1 deficit that is one excited
wrong on the Flyers [Applause] bench where's
the puck can't see it on this replay
yet and why did the whistle not go in
time and Mick you said it when it was
4 to one not 5 to one remember San
Jose yeah can't sit back and here
we are Clark scar from behind the
nut Dylan [Music] Lin it's 66 he on the
goal line oh my God he's behind the goal
[Applause]
line couldn't connect with rolin Go's
B the former flyer to Center on the
wing for lin with go sp there it is oh
what a stop oh what a save by Carter
[Music]
heart oh my oh my that is quite a read by heart
I mean you you don't have many bodies to worry
about on three on three like that you could
see this was coming either a front pass or
a drop pass by Lin and it's basically just a
redirect not a shot really by gos despare and
heart second shooter Raymond wide left
[Music] scores he didn't cool around
here one for one this
season Den ey
there can down way to the right side tried a
couple of moves that ryr really didn't go for
it I don't know if Rymer got a piece of that and
Patrick Kane can end it first shoot at attempt as
a Redwing two and one in the game Patrick Kane
scor Brad Wings win it 7-6 Patrick Kane what a
night [Music] wow gee and the hats Kenny they're
throwing hats on the ice it's an unofficial
Patrick not a hatrick cuz shootouts don't count in
your stats but we'll give Kane
the Patrick merry Christmas
everybody an excited Red Wings
bench I guess so after losing
a 5-1 lead they get an important two
points and hopefully this bodess well